es könnte der durchbruch im kampf gegen
korona sein
die oxford university meldete erste
erfolge bei tests mit einem impfstoff
gegen das virus die ergebnisse seien
vielversprechend und genau darüber
möchte ich mit klaus cichutek den
präsidenten des paul-ehrlich-instituts
sprechen herzig attack warum liegen denn
an der universitäten im bereich der
forschung im impfstoff schon vorne
insgesamt muss man zunächst bemerken
dass es großartig ist dass wir bereits
24 im stoff entwicklung von etwas
reduziert sich in der klinischen prüfung
haben und bereits auch fünf genehmigte
oder im ablauf befindliche klinische
prüfung der phase 3 vor also sicherheit
und wirksamkeit evaluiert wird soll die
unterschiede in bezug auf die jetzige
geschwindigkeit sind eigentlich nicht
sehr groß die riegen daran dass manche
entwickler schon erfahrung mit den
entsprechenden plattform bei entwicklung
anderer impfstoffe hatten hier aufsetzen
die unterschiede beruhen darauf dass
manche noch mal eine auswahl
unterschiedlicher impfstoffkandidaten
evaluieren andere ganz gezielt auf einen
kandidaten setzen was natürlich gewisse
risiken birgt und dann vielleicht die
unterschiede in der geschwindigkeit der
darstellung einer qualitätsgesicherten
herstellung insgesamt ist relevant dass
wir mindestens zu beginn nächsten jahres
mehrere zugelassene impfstoff kandidaten
brauchen die dann auch größere dosis
zahl zur verfügung stehen wie weit sind
die deutschen unternehmen cor weg und
bayern tag mit der entwicklung der
impfstoffe perfect und biotech spielen
wirklich ganz oben in der ersten liga
der impfstoffentwickler mit beide haben
einige nämliche klinischen prüfung in
deutschland weitere konsortium sind
gebildet und die ich gehe davon aus dass
im juli und dann auch später die fast
drei prüfungen beginnen werden
hier gibt es einmal die möglichkeit dass
in europa zu tun aber es gibt auch ideen
nach südamerika zu gehen oder südafrika
weil hier die infektionsraten
ausreichend sind
schneller eine antwort hinsichtlich der
wirksamkeit zu bekommen es gibt ja
derzeit auch einige studien die sich mit
der immunität der geheilten befassen
einige börsen jetzt dass sich die an die
kammer wieder verschwinden könnten aus
dem körper was sagen sie dazu
man muss hier unterscheiden es gibt im
moment ergebnisse dazu dass manche
weniger infektionen so verlaufen dass
weniger antikörper gebildet werden und
generell das antikörper die gebildet
wurden bei genesenen auch in dieser
intensität und bei dem täter nicht lange
bleiben
dazu muss man das scheiden das ja aber
bei impfstoffen ganz gezielt schützende
antikörper erzeugen müssen und natürlich
dann auch wert darauf gelegt wird das
durch zusätzliche sogenannte booster
impfungen
diese antikörper mengen im blut noch mal
gesteigert werden und dann hoffentlich
kai auch eine gewisse dauer haben um uns
vor der kurve 19 erkrankung zu schützen
war es für die ergebnisse abwarten
die chef forscherin der whu sagt dass es
schon nächstes nächsten jahres im mitte
nächsten jahres einen impfstoff geben
könnte gegen korona halten sie das für
realistisch ich bin da grundsätzlich der
gleichen meinung wenn wir das so
interpretieren dass sie davon ausgehen
dass wir schon in diesem jahr
einreichung bei joseph de vielleicht
auch bei der europäischen
arzneimittelagentur haben werden von
zulassungsanträgen für einzelne
impfstoff produkte dass wir noch mehrere
haben werden die die klinische prüfung
phase 3 hoffentlich geschafft haben zu
beginn nächsten jahres
und dann sind wir dabei jetzt natürlich
schon herstellungskapazitäten zu
erweitern und größere mengen von
impfstoff kandidaten schon jetzt
herzustellen im hinblick darauf dass sie
hoffentlich zugelassen werden können so
dass ich davon ausgehe dass wir mit den
nächsten jahres sogar mehrere impfstoff
produkte und noch relativ große dose
zahl auf dem markt haben werden